one of the more irritating leftist
tropes to emerge in the last year has
been the rise of fearless girl a hedge
fund sponsored bronze statue of a small
girl standing defiantly in front of the
Wall Street bow which would presumably
trample her to death both figures were
real now a democratic politician after
democratic politician has come forward
to pay homage to this bronze calf first
it was New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio who
criticized Wall Street the same Wall
Street that erected the annoyingly
stupid icon now it's senator Elizabeth
Warren who took a break from writing
shrimp recipes for Native American
cookbooks to demonstrate that she too
cares about metal effigies erected by
disproportionately male investment firms
and you know the picture is pretty
amazing she purchased in irritating the
rest of us more and of course has been
one of the lead Democratic voices in
favor of so-called pay equality between
men and women ignoring all statistical
evidence that the pay gap does not
actually exist when all relevant factors
are taken into account worth noting
warns female staffers earn 71% less than
her male staffers did last year
only one of Warren's top staffers earns
more than a hundred and thousand a
hundred thousand dollars and was female
but this is all virtue signaling of
course the notion is that if you don't
stand in solidarity with a little girl
against a giant bull you must hate women
and children somebody ought to inform
war in another leftist that the little
girl was once an unborn little girl and
more would then presumably stand with
the bowl I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
venture Pierrot show
all righty tongues to get seated a lots
of foreign policy news I feel like every
time I take off a couple of days the
world just reaches a new level of chaos
and so it is and so it shall be plus in
just a few minutes we're going to be
having on more in southern who of course
well-known right-wing commentator from
Canada and she was at the Berkeley riots
again Berkeley does not seem like a nice
place all these friendly hippies are not
that friendly and so we'll talk about
that starting to look like the biomart
Republic out there but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so I am NOT somebody who
sleeps well I require a very comfortable
mattress and wonderful sheets helix
sleep provides the very very comfortable
mattress its helix sleep calm slash BAM
the way this works you go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben get fifty dollars off
your order but they also will ask you
your height your weight your body type
do you like to sleep on your stomach or
your side and they use an algorithm
proprietary algorithm to determine what
kind of mattress will work best for you
and then they send it to your house the
shipping is free they send it to your
house and if you don't like it you have
a hundred nights it to try it out and
then you can send it right back he looks
customers reported thirty percent
improvement in overall sleep quality my
wife and I had a much more expensive
mattress actually and we moved it out of
the room in favor of the helix mattress
because the helix mattress is so
comfortable its helix sleep calm slash
Ben you got fifty dollars off your order
again it comes in a big box you just
unroll the box and it inflates
automatically because it's a foam
mattress it's really comfortable unlike
a lot of other foam mattresses you can
get ones that really breathe well so it
doesn't feel like you're you're in a
kiln and yeah I really like the mattress
a lot so does my wife I can't recommend
it highly enough plus it's no risk to
you because if you hate it then you can
always send it back for free so that's
great it's he would sleep calm slash Ben
helix sleep calm slash spend $50 off
your order I promise you won't hate it
you'll actually like it a lot of
fantastic product okay so lots going on
in the world among the things that are
going on in the world the the Trump
administration continues to kind of futz
around on foreign policy and we'll talk
about that but first I want to talk
about the fallout that happen from this
election in the Georgia six district
last night so Georgia six district is a
district that I think Trump won by
relatively small margin you want to buy
1.5 or 2% because there's been some
redistricting there there has been some
significant movement in that district
over time four years ago Barack Obama
lost that district by 23% to Mitt Romney
so this particular district last night
there was a there's a runoff because Tom
price was the representative from that
district and now Tom price is the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
so then John Asaf he's Democrat he
doesn't even live in the district and he
ran against a slew of Republicans I
think there were 11 Republicans and the
idea was that if he crosses 50% in this
original election then he wouldn't the
seat outright if he doesn't cross 50%
there's a runoff if there's a runoff he
likely loses because it's a heavier
Republican district so Democrats poured
a crapload of money into this district
they poured 8.3 million dollars into
this local special election trying to
demonstrate that they were going to
fight back against the Trump
administration and that was a giant fail
so the candidate John Asaf want about
the same percentage in the district as
Hillary Clinton won in the district he
came up just short one of the reasons he
came up just short is because he doesn't
actually live in the district and that
came out a couple of days before the
actual election no that's not illegal
but obviously most people who vote for
their congressperson like to know the
person actually lives where they were
they represent there was a soft
yesterday trying to explain why he
doesn't live in home district well I
grew up in this district I grew up in
this community it's my home my family is
still there I'm a mile and a half down
the street to support Alicia while she
finishes medical school it's something
I've been very transparent about in fact
I'm proud to be supporting her career
and as soon as she finishes her medical
training I'll be ten minutes back up the
road into the district where I grew up
okay so in that explanation did not
really do a lot for him he's not going
to win the general election in all
likelihood because again now all the
Republican votes are going to
consolidate he want to make 46% 47% of
the vote last night all of that all that
Republican support is going to now rally
around a woman I actually know pretty
well karen handel
who used to be an executive at a komen
for the Cure the the anti cancer
Institute she has been the Georgia
Secretary of State before she ran
unsuccessfully for governor in the past
but really nice lady very very quality
politician she's not somebody who gets
enthusiasm up high but she will do the
work that she needs to do
we win that's why I saw yesterday after
he did not win outright he was out there
touting it as a victory for the ages
maybe the entire Democratic Party is now
trying to overstate how big a victory
this was for them because he didn't win
so now they're trying to say that he
blew it out of the water and this is
just what's to come under Trump that the
Democrats are going to win back the
house here is Asaf overstating his case
there is no doubt that this is already a
victory for the ages a victory for the
ages no let's not overstate the case
dude you couldn't win an election in
which there were a combined it looks
like less than 200,000 votes I'm going
to go with that's not a victory for the
ages especially if you don't end up with
the congressional seats most of the
people who talk about moral victories
are losers if you're talking about moral
victory it's because you didn't win so
there are some troubling signs for
Republicans here the most troubling sign
for Republicans in the Georgia 6 to be
accurate is that the Democratic turnout
was down from the general election cycle
but it wasn't down nearly as much as it
was down among Republicans so if you
look at the Georgia sixth or the Kansas
fourth Kansas fourth district was
another case where there was a special
election Republicans won that one too
but the Democratic turnout was down 25
percent from the Hillary election in
this district in the special election
the Republicans turnout was down 51
percent from the last election cycle in
this election so in other words twice as
many Republicans as Democrats by
percentage dropped out of this election
cycle and that's not going to bode well
for midterms because obviously Democrats
are going to be more geared up for all
of this it's a little early to say that
this just demonstrates that Trump is not
hurting people down ballot in fact the
the number of candidates who ran in this
Georgia sixth district the people who
are more closely tied with Trump there
is a heavy correlation between them
being closely tied with Trump and not
doing particularly well in this election
cycle but it's not clear what's going to
happen in 2018 based on this Democrats
raised in enormous amounts of money as I
said they put forward a huge huge amount
of cash in this election and they still
weren't able to get this guy over the
top you know it's going to be a good
Democratic here but it's going to be a
good enough Democratic here to put them
over the top
I don't know that that's the case and
the media in search of some sort of
victory are of course overstating this
dramatically Don Lemon a TN and he says
that John
you saw him John awesome he looks like
he looks like the guy from Ferris
Bueller who's not Ferris Bueller the guy
who drives his dad's Porsche out the
window
hey John lemon says he sounds like Obama
so that was John Asaf in a very tight
race down in Atlanta he's projecting
that's going to be a rough I the only
one that said he sounded like Barack
Obama no does that sound like Barack
Obama yes he did university years ago so
you know and say I heard for him yes we
can John I yeah everybody on CNN so
laboratory after not getting what they
want here it is amazing that that he
raised that much money and again he
raised that much money and it still
didn't help him that looks a lot like
what happened with Hillary Clinton who
raised an enormous amount of money and
it didn't help her against Trump but
there are some more in science for
Republicans and Republicans would be
wise to pay attention to those warning
signs now meanwhile over the weekend I
have a chance to discuss it obviously
because it was Passover but over the
weekend there was this riot that
occurred in Berkeley basically there's a
pro Trump rally in Berkeley the only
reason to have a pro Trump rally in
Berkeley is to stick it to the left and
Berkeley obviously and a bunch of anti
Trump and Tifa characters these are the
people who could consume themselves
antifascist there's nothing more fascist
than showing up to an opposing rally and
then whaling on people and beating the
living crap out of them it's actually
pretty reminiscent of the Vermont
Republic where the Reds and the Browns
were beating the living crap out of each
other and that actually led to the rise
of a more dictatorial authoritarian
government that's usually what happens
when there's chaos people want more
authority in order to camp down on cats
because nobody wants to see this in
their straits apparently the cops we're
sitting by and doing nothing as all of
this continued here's a little bit of
the footage from what was happening
during this during this bloody battle
basically
I think you will beating each other with
sticks you can see they're really going
at each other really hitting each other
punching each other running in duking it
out their pictures of people who are
super bloody there are people people
who've been hit across the face and
wasn't the Trump people who started it
wasn't different people what they're
looking to find now is empty but you can
always tell me the bad guy those yeah
they're stomping on an island it's
disgusting
hitting people of skateboards are really
really horrifying you can always tell
the bad guys are in the situation people
who are wearing the mask says the bad
guy feels the need to wear a mask
because you're afraid that people are
going to pay attention to you see who
you are and arrest you then you are part
of the problem not part of the solution
this was a free speech rally so people
were doing this in order to demonstrate
that they would stand up against the
antifa the antifa
group and and the antiva people showed
up and they were beating people some
won't one of the people there pulled
metal in the escape or but then pulled a
knife apparently somebody was stabbed I
mean just egregious egregious stuff and
where are the cops for all of us why are
the cops allowing all of this stuff to
go ahead nobody knows why where's the
mayor I mean this is now the second time
that this has happened in Berkeley in a
relative span of months it's the third
time if I remember correctly there's a
rally that broken violence here there's
one that broke into violence in
Sacramento at the capital in California
and then there was of course the riot
that broke out when Miley innopolis want
to speak over there well joining us on
the program right now is Laura in
southern more in southern was there she
of course is it well-known on Twitter
and on YouTube Canadian conservative
libertarian political commentator and
provocateur she's the author of the book
barbarians how baby boomers immigrants
in Islam screwed my generation you can
follow her on Twitter at Lauren
underscore southern or on YouTube as
Lauren southern Lauren thanks so much
for joining the show appreciate it
hi Ben thanks for having me so Lauren
can you give me some details because I'm
just seeing sort of the second-hand
coverage as you were there so what
exactly went down yeah we're sure well
we were supposed to every time there
have been a pro Trump Pro free speech
right wing event in Berkeley it has been
shut down by militant leftists and the
people there are just so sick and tired
of it so they said no more we're not
going to live in a world in Berkeley
where we cannot
have a certain political idea without
fear of being physically injured so they
had an even bigger rally this time and
the police assured myself and the
organizers that there would be an
impressive presence there that the left
wouldn't be able to shut it down this
time but it was under one condition that
the police would be there that everyone
that went into this protected zone by
the police disarms that we didn't have
any sticks any bear mace any pepper
spray so all the Trump supporters went
into this kind of they put up a little
mesh orange fence around an area where
we were going to have a free speech
event and then anti-flash showed up and
started surrounding the place around a
bunch of disarmed people but we were
like you know it's going to be fine the
cops are here we're good then
auntie Flo starts throwing m-80s little
explosives and fireworks and suddenly
boom the cops were gone they had gotten
stand down orders and we were left in
the center of this area surrounded by an
tyfa totally disarmed and things just
turned into chaos
it was fists flying everywhere it's
absolutely insane and did you ever get
an explanation from the police as to who
actually ordered the stand-in right well
that was that's the interesting but I
was really frustrated during it I was
like I can't believe the cops did that
but another journalist went up to the
cops and asked them why are you standing
down and one of the guys sitting in the
front seat said well that would be a
question for a boss wouldn't it and he
looked really mad so it wasn't the
individual costume someone from higher
up for sure pretty typical I mean even
when I speak at college campuses and the
cops get skinned down orders never the
cops it's always the people who are in
charge of the cops telling them they
need to stand down on this sort of thing
so for people who don't know what an
Tifa is you've obviously now had
dealings with them what are ante foe
what do they think they're doing and why
are they doing it
they are the anti-fascists they actually
come from a wing of the German Communist
Party and very militant group that
believed by any means possible
anything that can remotely be perceived
as right-wing anything to the right of
marks basically has to be shut down
violently and they use a tactic called
black bloc where they cover all their
faces so that they can commit crimes
because the cops can't know who did it
and one of the big tactics they use
during this one was they would grab
individuals from this crowd and they'd
pull them to the back and start beating
the crap out of them so their tactics
are always cover their face to commit
crimes and ten people versus one and
it's really kind of its really scary
going against them because they have
neuro morals zero whatsoever they're
hurtling bricks and giant rocks into the
crowd literal attempted murder would
have killed someone if it hit them in
the face there any arrested this thing
or literally it just sort of ended in
everybody went home at the beginning
there were a couple arrests of an tyfa
that were trying to go over the mesh and
I guess transporters that were trying to
fight back so there are a few at the
beginning and after the fact when the
police had just disappeared they looked
at a few of the videos and made a couple
of rests I think there were 11 or 12
arrests in total so one of the things
that's probably on all this is that a
few if you look at the media coverage of
it they treat it as though it's just
sort of spontaneous chaos that erupts
between the two sides though nobody
actually launched the chaos in the same
way that when Milo went to speak at
Berkeley and then the Antipa people
showed up and tried to burn down no
schools basically that that was in it
was in equal distribution of blame that
it was half Milo's fault and half the
protesters fault and here is half the
Trump people's fault that the Trump
people hadn't been there being so
provocative then it wouldn't have
wouldn't been up to the ante for people
to hit them what do you make of all the
media coverage BBC actually uploaded one
of those little short videos to Facebook
where they slice together the tax
protests and this Berkeley protest and
wrote that Trump supporters showed up to
the tax protest and started attacking
the anti-trump protesters they that's
exactly what they did after I called
them out on Twitter they've made a few
edits to the Facebook post but that was
the coverage just complete and utter
lies that's beyond fake news it's
deliberately laughing to people and they
knew what they were doing so I it's it's
horrifying the state of media I couldn't
believe the coverage Apple is I mean we
saw that obviously throughout the
campaign we kept hearing that it was
Trump who's pushing violence at his
rallies but then it would be it would be
protesters from black lives matter
shutting down an actual Trump rally in
Chicago or protestors from the left
beating the crap out of Trump supporters
in San Jose it is amazing how the media
is able to flip this on its head so are
you guys planning any more of these
events and if you do plan these events
in the future
how can you do that knowing that you
know if anybody from from the pro Trump
side or the pro free-speech sex doesn't
matter if you like Trump or not it's
really more of a free speech issue from
the pro free speech side if anybody
shows
with a weapon you'll probably
immediately be arrested but if anybody
from the left shows up with a weapon and
they probably get off scot-free well Ann
Coulter is supposed to be speaking on
the 27th I can't get too much into it
but I think there's some troubles
already with that event with Berkeley
trying to shut it down and the this is
think we're at the point where we have
to defend ourselves I don't like to see
that the state of political discourse in
2017 is fists and mace instead of signs
and borns but that's the reality is that
we have to defend ourselves I can't
blame the Trump supporters for punching
back or the free speech activists for
punching back because the cops are gone
so I think this is going to continue to
escalate until the police stop getting
stand-down orders in Berkeley yeah so
what do you think just a final question
here how much things you think are the
students at Berkeley and how much is it
this outside groove antifa there's a lot
of talk about that with Milo speaking
there that it wasn't really a bunch of
the it wasn't really a bunch of lefties
from Berkeley it was really the 10th
Aoife group that was coming from outside
infiltrating and then making trouble
here it looks like a bunch of antifa
people and I spoke at Berkeley two years
ago it was not a problem at all
obviously Milo speak there's a riot and
coulter is going to speak there they'll
probably will be a riot I think it's
cause a antifa was not a presence when I
was there a couple of years ago and it
seems like a pretty recent development
but how much of this do you think is
organic and how much of this is
astroturf
well I will say I was I went to walk
around the area before the event and
everywhere in Berkeley the whole damn
city is covered in spray paint that says
auntie fuzz own and that could be people
that have come in there were definitely
people that were brought in from
different areas to fight like the one
girl who'd up decked in the face she
drove down from quite a while to be
there but it's definitely been over the
past two years I would say these kids
also in university have been radicalized
more and more and more over the media
saying all right wingers are Nazis of
course they want to fight and stop
Nazism it was when they've watched
Indiana Jones and glorious bastards they
want to get their 100 Nazi scalps right
and they've truly been convinced this
last year that Trump supporters of free
speech activists are not see so it's the
mix between people coming down and
between young people being radicalized
over the past year or in southern thanks
so much for doing what you're doing
Lawrence either you can follow her at
learn southern on Twitter it's more an
underscore southern or on youtube is
Lauren sunny she has terrific work
Lauren thanks so much for joining the
show appreciation thanks for having me
okay so before we continue with the
analysis of what Trump is doing on
foreign policy and it's a real mixed bag
there there's a there's a bunch of stuff
happening on foreign policy that
demonstrate continued divided mind among
the members of the Trump administration
I want to stop and say thank you to our
sponsors over at blue apron so if you
are sick of eating at over-salted and
overpriced restaurants if you would
prefer to eat at home great recipes you
can home cook you could spend time
cooking with your kids it's something I
enjoy doing with my my three-year-old
then what you can do is you can
subscribe over at blue apron blue apron
is the number one service in America
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country and they send you
a new recipe every single day with all
of the ingredients that are parceled out
already for the meal so you don't have
to worry about measuring you don't have
to worry about you screwed up the recipe
it's all done for you you just put it
together in the pan and everything cooks
in less than 45 minutes it is less than
$10 a day per person for a delicious
meal and the blue apron families
obviously cook a lot more than people
who are not who ate breakfast a hassle
to go shopping for all of the
ingredients I remember years ago my wife
suggested would it be great if there was
a service to did this for you now blue
apron does do it for you blue apron comm
slash Shapiro and some of their featured
upcoming meals when these are all like
gourmet meals you don't have to be a
gourmet to cook them because they tell
you exactly what to do it stuff like
sweet and sour salmon with bok choy
carrot and ginger fried rice baby
broccoli and Fontana paninis with
hard-boiled egg and regular salad
spinach and fresh mozzarella pizza with
olives bell peppers and ricotta salata
if you don't like a recipe they won't
repeat it for you and the recipes rotate
all the times you have to get bored with
your diet you know that's a issue in our
house where you have the same thing
every Tuesday night and godnot casserole
night again you never have to deal with
that again with blue apron comm again
it's fresh it's flexible it's easy if
the ingredients are bad they'll resend
them to you obviously because it's a
guaranteed the freshness check out this
week's menu get your first three meals
free when you go to blue apron comm
slash appear Oh blue apron comm slash
appear oh you will love how good it
feels and taste to create these
incredible home-cooked meals they are
first-rate everybody in LA is now using
blue apron comm so blue apron comm slash
apparel get those first three meals free
try it out and I promise you'll be
addicted really really quickly okay so
meanwhile on foreign policy there's a
lot of chaos going on all over the world
I want to take a kind of area by area
because
there's a lot of lack of clarity out
there on everything from North Korea to
Turkey to Iran so a big story of the day
is that the Trump administration has now
stated that Iran is abiding by its
commitments under the under the Obama
nuclear deal this is just a terrible
move by the Trump administration it is
asinine to suggest that everything is
hunky-dory with regard to Iran that Iran
is doing everything that it can to abide
by the nuclear deal they obviously are
not there have been multiple reports
then not only are they violating it with
regard to attempting to buy certain
types of uranium on the open market but
also they have been violating the
nuclear deal by test firing ballistic
missiles they've been doing that
repeatedly since November and yet this
is from Rex Tillerson he says the u.s.
Department of State certified to US
House Speaker Paul Ryan today that Iran
is compliant through April 18th with its
commitments under the joint
comprehensive plan of action however the
secretary also raised concerns about
Iran's role as a state sponsor of
terrorism and alert in Congress to an
effort to rested by the President to
evaluate whether continuing to what
sanctions would be in US national
security interests they're trying to
split the baby saying everything is
hunky-dory under the deal the easiest
thing to do would be to say they're not
complying with the deal therefore the
sanctions are back on the table they
immediately snapback and we're done here
this deal is a crap deal there's no
reason why we should be involved this
way but I think there's a split inside
the Trump administration they don't want
to start some sort of firefight
politically with Iran they are obviously
divided on what to do about Iran because
Iran is sponsoring Assad and they're
divided about what to do about Assad
they are not sure that Iran is is not a
solidifying influence in Iraq this is
always my fear about trumpian foreign
policy is that it's just so vague and
and so all over the place that it opens
the door to the continued growth of evil
regimes like Iran but that's not the
only problem with Trump foreign policy
that's cropped up this week I want to
talk about Turkey and North Korea but
we'll do that if you go and subscribe go
to Dover to daily wire comm become a
subscriber to the podcast $8 a month
gets you a subscription to daily wire
comm you get the rest of the show live
you get to be part of the mailbag which
will be doing on Friday this week you
get the clayvin show live
you also get right now a free copy of
the arroyo fictional film set on the
southern border plus we have lots of
goodies coming up we're going to give
you discounts on a bun
new products that are coming up from the
long-awaited Shapiro store which will
happen daily wired.com go over there and
check it out for an annual subscriber
you get that copy of the arroyo DVD it
is a great service great movie and
you're going to want to be part of the
daily wire team so go over to daily wire
and icon become a subscriber otherwise
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud later
and become a subscriber and if you do
become a subscriber make sure to leave a
review at iTunes that always helps in
the iTunes rankings where we are as
always the top rated conservative
podcast in the United States
[Music]
you